welcome to video playing Boris slow
that's Boris something I knew his name
Boris sloping again okay so can I do
something different maybe maybe I can go
for and it's called a very high rating
it's high rating for the sky I'm trying
the blue without gambit um okay what
exactly was my intended move after this
before Wow Bishop g5
I was at age 60 my know what taking and
i know i remember now i remember it took
me a while in d6 answers while i studied
a while back sorry only if I think this
is right
and yep and white eggs on b5 it doesn't
take on before yeah I don't know what
what what about this line I think I have
to go before not i'm not mistaken yeah
to become be no new type of position
should have played I should have played
them Eve Eve five probably anyway trying
to get the Bishop to b5 here need to get
it traded wreck we play Bishop g4
actually it was an option as well anyway
it seems playable we've got a very
nice-looking Bishop 106 and he has to
worry about the a5 pawn
just getting out and out of possible
tempe and so we got this traded so let's
see dark squares I need the bishop here
do I want to play a five year and this
is a position where yeah i think i wanta
what is that wrong f5 he cannot take at
the moment then then maybe let's do it
it's if it's a bit dicey but I'd see
yeah i was thinking f4 takes Queen age
floor I think this is interesting
playing completely on the dark squares
twin f6 is also possible okay he went
there so what to do Queen f6 is
attacking d3 but maybe this one for I
have three and so prevented that one I
can go Queen g5 now for possible Bishop
g5 yeah I'm going to take and go Bishop
b5 that is going to be dangerous for
white so Luke chicks route chief is
coming yeah well okay look for what is
he doing look III then you probably
wants to play look f2 so look at eight
rook f2 I guess Rock g43
some aged five not sure about it is a
point is quick I mean
yeah so this will be interesting he just
hopes that this is not going to kill him
i also have aged 3 as a possible move
yeah i think i'll take with the bishop
and just hope that this is winning while
I know working somehow you cannot really
calculate this now at this this
particular moment but i don't really
believe that this should be okay for him
so what is this Bishop back was some
other move look a 44 queen yeah okay
this is I can do this yeah that should
be enough
they can promote always at some pretty
serious business
root g three htx Queen g3 that's Luke
age for that should win some attacking
with checks all the way if it promotes a
eight Queen g4 check kingi tool and
bishop yeah be sure well f2 probably
cringing I've got age three check as
well this one just covers that
interesting over time morning
don't have much time here if he promotes
i'll just play Bishop e3 and hope that
this works might might might be the case
don't don't see you when yeah I don't
believe it each one now you can just
trade I'm losing this game I don't
believe this nonsense come on come on I
know I would now entry why is he not
just promoting come on I just this is
just laughs this is just utter rubbish
ear there is no meteor don't give me
that it's unbelievable okay of course
there's the submit but I don't see it as
usual it's just- similarly NM I of
course it is so how where's the mate
Bishop takes their Bishop f4 is made but
that also should win rook f1 is winning
look f1 let's meet so but this probably
not know that also wins see four winds
uh-huh seaforth also made I didn't see
that that dentists I'm attacking here
and so see four different Queens then
I'm taking at this wins yeah I need to
need to kill that defender on the
third-ranked yeah check this is now not
defensible anymore now I didn't see it I
simply didn't see it okay this is
ridiculous because he can trade Queens I
didn't see that but instead i mean
really i only have c4 here to win or do
I have other moves
yeah probably not yet I probably have to
do that it wasn't even so badly played
this this was this was clear I it seems
attacking here and here I'm going with g
one but probably this also wins I mean
it's really Chinese flow everything
winds here just not the one line that I
played her I didn't seek when you won
though he was finally he found that may
it's not exactly rocket science as 24
was the threat but I didn't seek windy
one at all and this one I know I just
have to go see four and that's it about
any other move even this is still okay
yeah some some rubbish move I don't know
okay thanks for watching